welcome to the reason stream I'm Zach
Weissmuller joined by Liz Wolfe and
today's conversation will Mark another
entry in what's shaped into a kind of
pandemic retrospective series covid-19
changed the world and for a Time ushered
in the kind of heavy-handed government
interventions that were previously
unimaginable to many of us in 21st
century America
it's important to avoid dwelling
endlessly on the past but the world
can't afford to let what unfolded in
2020 happen again and if we don't take a
full accounting of what exactly went
wrong during covid as well as which
policies were effective and respectful
of our basic Liberties it'll be far too
easy for many of the same Unapologetic
politicians pundits and public officials
to lead us further down a destructive
path and that's why it's time to talk
about Sweden the one European country
that didn't follow the herd and locked
down
so why did Sweden resist and what
ultimately happened there Our Guest
today is Johan Norberg and he's going to
help us understand all of that he's an
author and Senior fellow at the Cato
Institute who recently published a
report called Sweden during the pandemic
Pariah or Paragon Johann thank you for
joining us today
thanks for having me on the show
and to start Johan help us understand
exactly what the reality on the ground
in Sweden was during the early days of
the pandemic you were there what was it
like
yeah well you know life wasn't uh normal
in Sweden during that time because we
all had this perception that something
scary was going on in the world so we
did have lots of social distancing and
people working from home and didn't have
the same ability around towns as we
usually do
but
on a voluntary basis this was based on
mostly on recommendations from the
government rather than bans we didn't
have policemen investigating why we went
to the shop or met friends and relatives
or went to a restaurant or a bar and
that made Sweden seem very different
from most other places that we heard
about at the time so different from what
we would normally be like but much more
different from other parts of the world
yeah I mean I remember seeing the images
that were published of Sweden at the
time and some of the b-roll that would
run on newscasts and it looked fairly
bustling it you know it was like yeah
and they're contrasting this with just
an abandoned Times Square or whatever
um I mean you but you're saying that it
was not by any means normal uh were did
you what was your reaction to the way
things were portrayed in pictures and in
media what how accurate was that
well you know many of those pictures
were taken from a specific angle so that
you can see a crowd even though it might
be a several feet or meters between them
there was this attempt by I think almost
the whole world to portray swedeness
we're like this this crazy outlier where
we just go about business as usual and
we don't care about how many people
suffer and die because of it and I think
partly because so many were investigated
in their own National lockdowns so there
had to be something wrong with the
swedes but as a matter of fact even
though again it was different from what
you would see in Times Square
um it was the case that Mobility was
reduced quite dramatically you could see
that in mobile phone operators then they
could see that Sweden
abandoned public transportation and work
from home and so on almost as much as
our Nordic neighbors but we did it on a
voluntary basis which gave us that
loophole if you really needed to go
somewhere be somewhere be with someone
you could do it and in a weird ironic
way I think that helps weeds to stick to
social distancing for longer because it
wasn't imposed from above it was imposed
by people just don't want to hurt
themselves and their loved ones did any
journalists actually stop to consider
the cell phone tracking data that you're
referencing
I didn't see much of that we we heard it
from Swedish the Swedish public health
authority uh looking at weekly reports
and telling looking at the data and
showing that it's quite similar to to
other places
um uh but it wasn't much of music media
interest well the thing that was so
interesting to me being in the U.S is
watching so many journalists be
cheerleaders um for the pandemic policy
advocated by by Anthony fauci in Sweden
what was that Dynamic like were most
journalists supportive of Anders
Danielle's strategy or were they highly
critical how did that work
I would say that we had a healthy debate
and that's what you should have right
and the media shouldn't be sure leaders
for any kind of of policy and I think
partly because we had we didn't
politicize the pandemic like other
countries did because there wasn't this
sort of government command and control
system where everybody's supposed to do
it in one particular way that creates
all manners of resentments and questions
about what is this really based upon
whereas if there's a recommendation
um and people are allowed to make their
own decisions it isn't as heavily
politicized and I think the healthier
debate in Sweden reflected that but when
it comes to what the public perceived
and and the general attitude you can see
that uh swedes generally were in
agreement with the Swedish policies uh
there was always a majority in favor of
those policies and between 10 to 20
percent in favor of them stricter and
more more harsh lockdown so it was not a
um a winner to come out and be in favor
of lockdowns
yeah I think there's uh it's worth
appreciating that point you're making
about the voluntary nature of the social
distancing at the beginning there uh
because there's often this embedded
assumption that uh this can only be
achieved by a government policy and
clearly Sweden is a counter example to
that and yeah when you're taking photos
that portray something that it is a
misleading picture I remember the same
thing happening uh in the early days of
floor in Florida when they reopened the
beaches there would be these long angle
I mean these long lenses that uh make
the beach look like everyone is crowded
together on the beach and then if you
you know take it with a shorter lens you
see that people are actually on the
beach outside social distancing probably
one of the safest activities that you
know now we know that you could be
engaging in
so you know and then the the voluntary
aspect as as you laid out there uh
allows for
some learning and adaptation as as we
learn more rather than you being stuck
in this
uh top-down imposed policy I think it's
worth digging into exactly what the
policy
of Sweden was and I've pulled a slide
from the the government's
um
this is their post covid commission so
they looked at what did we do what right
what did we do wrong and at the
beginning here they lay out what the
policy actually was and they say
Sweden's Disease Control measures have
largely been based on a voluntary
approach and the responsibility of each
individual the commission considers that
the focus on recommendations which
people are expected to follow
voluntarily has been fundamentally
correct so they stand by the policy at
the end of the day they've got some
caveats which we'll get into later but
then at the end they also mentioned that
the Swedish Health Care System managed
to adapt rapidly and was for the most
part able to offer care to those falling
ill with covid-19
um
one of the things that you hear a lot
about when we talk about the the
voluntary nature of Sweden's approach is
that
maybe it worked for Sweden because
there's something cultural there that
that that people are are more willing to
do the responsible thing
um can you talk to that point is that an
aspect of Swedish culture that made it
work particularly well there
I think it's worth
investigating and
researching whether this is a factor for
sure there's more of a high degree of
social trust in Sweden trust in your
neighbors and and the government than in
other places so perhaps it's enough with
recommendations then people will just
just follow the the recommendation you
don't need the band that's one possible
argument on the other hand I think it's
interesting to see what happened during
the pandemic in Sweden compared to other
places because trust doesn't come from
nowhere I mean it's also the result of
how how you behave how authorities
behave and Sweden is actually one of few
countries where we see an increased
trust in the public health agency in uh
many of the um
people who who led the Swedish covet
response and we also saw more of trust
in things like medical interventions uh
vaccines we didn't get the same kind of
anti-vaxx movement in Sweden as we did
in other places so perhaps it's it's a
bit of a chicken and an egg problem
perhaps it's the case that we didn't
have a public health authority that with
the force of of the police and
government legislation and bans forced
people to behave in a certain way that
actually made us trust those authorities
more than you do in other places where
it sometimes it's just sort of the
individual preferences of some of the
these experts and agencies that suddenly
ruins your everyday lifestyle then it's
easy to to lack trust in in that system
was there any anti-vaxxer movement
actually before this arose in Sweden
because one thing that I'm thinking
about is how like the U.S to some degree
um had a strong history of of vaccine
refusal vaccine dissenters you know
starting in the 90s and early Arts
especially with like the Andrew
Wakefield
um study and you know Britain also had
the same thing so like I could imagine
that perhaps the reason why that didn't
crop up in Sweden is maybe because it
wasn't already there do you have any
insight there just really briefly yeah
that could be swedes love vaccines just
give it to me and and we do it and
partly that could be uh this General
trust in in authorities uh yeah in
medical authorities in the high rate of
autism no no just kidding
I think one interesting thing though is
that
it's always been voluntary to go and get
vaccines in Sweden we have other places
in Italy for example where it's
mandatory traditional sort of childhood
vaccines and so on and that leads to
distrust in vaccines in Italy or at
least it's much higher than than it is
in Sweden so I also think this
sensitivity this uh being open to the
fact that if you really don't want to do
something you don't have to that gives
people you're more relaxed about the
things even authorities you know to that
point it's also interesting Sweden seems
to have been more willing than the
United States to acknowledge the
different risks that different
populations face from the virus namely
not closing schools at all it seems like
in terms of mask mandates in schools
that was not a big thing even on
vaccines I noticed right here that
Sweden is not even recommending vaccines
for kids age 5 to 11 and this is the
kind of thing that
is extremely still controversial in the
United States but there's a more sort of
careful analysis it seems to me of sub
populations and and their their relative
risks
what do you think explains that
well I'm gonna have to ask why American
authorities don't think about things in
the same way because it seems quite
reasonable if you're doing certain
non-medical interventions because you
want to protect people and Society you'd
better know how to protect them and who
is most at risk otherwise it's uh you
risk losing sight of the real problems
but you also risk unintended
consequences this was one of the reasons
why Sweden never shut down schools it
was the sense that children aren't
severely affected didn't seem like they
spread the virus as much as adults in
that case if we shut down schools we're
going to ruin their education and then
social integration for months and that
might be worse than what happens to them
if they they catch the virus so to me it
just seems like a reasonable thing to do
and you have to ask why American
authorities don't think the same way
yeah this is something that this is
something that's sort of close to our
hearts and I would imagine at this point
our live stream viewers might be a
little bit sick of our slight fixation
on this but I mean I have a baby and
Zach has three young children and so to
some degree I kind of want to linger on
the impact that U.S policy making
surrounding coronavirus had on young
children because I mean it just seems
absolutely crazy to me that the
population least at risk of terrible
consequences uh ended up in in many ways
being the most hurt by this and so
looking at policies like Sweden's the
fact that you know primary school
children were still able to like
interact with each other and be unrest
and play outside and all of these things
like I mean I live in New York City
where we literally had playgrounds being
padlocked so I think it's actually you
know Although our viewers might at this
point be sick of us dwelling on this I
just think that this is a really crucial
thing to hammer home I did want to ask
uh Johan so one thing that I noticed in
the clip that Zach had just pulled up is
a little bit of the Swedish authorities
the Swedish Health authorities touting
the Health Care system and talking about
how you know
um
the Swedish Healthcare System managed to
adapt rapidly and was for the most part
able to offer care to those falling ill
with covid-19 although this required
significant sacrifices
um do you have any thoughts on this
because I feel like Swedish Healthcare
System there are a lot of Bernie Sanders
supporters in the United States who tout
this as the ideal
um how did the Swedish Health Care
System handle kovid and do you have any
complicating factoids to draw in that
might dissuade some Sanders types from
either supporting this the Swedish
system or wanting to emulate socialized
medicine in the United States
yeah that's a good question because as
many
it's a long way to Sweden and it's easy
to misunderstand how the system works um
Sweden doesn't have a national
single-payer uh Healthcare System and
like some other countries it's based on
the regions the 20 plus Swedish regions
uh they're in charge of it and most of
the funding comes from the regional
taxes which is a a flat tax of regional
and and local income taxes rather than
anything else and it's also being
changed over the past three decades
because it didn't work that well when it
was all sort of regional public
hospitals and healthcare workers so it's
been opened up to private providers and
many of and it's also you get the same
kind of funding if you're a private and
accepted private provider of Health Care
and that means that there's more
flexibility in the system than it was
before and this is something that other
countries the national
single-payer system they said that this
is a reason why Sweden will not adapt
very well to the pandemic because it's
not control top down it's got all these
moving parts and uh also so many
um
groups institutions that couldn't be be
easily controlled but actually turned
out that this made it easier to adapt
and rapidly scale up things like
intensive care units which was doubled
in a very short time so we never hit the
ceiling we never had more patients than
than hospital beds as many of these
models where you just extrapolated how
many 20 to 30 patients would be fighting
over every single hospital bed that
never happened in Sweden we even had a
big field Hospital built not far from
here in Stockholm and to receive all
those patients but journalists waited in
vain afterwards
outside because it never had to open
because the normal institutions could
rapidly scale up
yeah and uh we're gonna get to some of
the projections in a little bit which
were off worldwide but specifically in
Sweden what was projected versus the
actual outcome but first I do want to
return for a second to the media
coverage because I think it's an
important component to examine because
Sweden did play this role of the
contrarian it was a very inconvenient
counter example to all these other
countries in the world that had locked
down and this was the kind of coverage
that you would see the New York Times in
July 2020 Sweden has become the world's
cautionary tale you had uh them saying
that Sweden put stock in the sensibility
of its people and for that grave sin the
coronavirus is blamed for 54 5420 deaths
which is 40 percent more than you us per
million people 12 times more than Norway
seven times more than Finland six times
more than Denmark we heard a lot of
these comparisons to Sweden's Nordic
Neighbors in particular Donald Trump was
out there tweeting Sweden is paying
heavily for its decision not to lock
down the United States made the correct
decision we've got a clip from Trump
that I'm we're going to play here where
he's making essentially the same point
let's roll that
uh now they talk about Sweden but Sweden
is suffering very Gravely you know that
right Sweden did that the herd they call
it the herd uh Sweden's suffering very
very badly uh it's a way of doing it but
uh the you know everybody has been
watching everybody else and so forth
almost every country has done it the way
we've done it we've chosen to do it if
we didn't do it that way we would have
lost hundreds of thousands of more
people okay
and then I want to get your reaction in
a second Johan but first just back to
back with that clip I want to play a
clip of what you were saying in that
same period that was from April 7th
2020. this was from about a week later
what you were saying about the
experience in Sweden and what how people
should think about it let's roll the
clip of Johan from April 2020. my
personal point of view
I'm not an APD meology homologist I
can't even pronounce the word
um it seems like I'm obviously not an
expert when it comes to these issues but
so far I'm broadly sympathetic to the
Swedish model
restricting freedoms might be necessary
during pandemics but only when we have
good reasons to assume that this will
help us when it comes to our long-term
health and when we don't know I think to
what we do know as John Stuart once put
it in every instance the burden of
making out a strong case lies not on
those who resist but on those who
recommend government interference
so that was a very humble and cautious
defense of Sweden's approach what was it
like for for you during that time period
uh you know cautiously defending Sweden
amidst this Firestorm of criticism of
the country's approach
yeah we weren't popular at that time and
both of
friend foreign friends and foreign media
got in touch and asked me are you all
crazy have you gone crazy over there
because it's there's a pandemic and you
seems like you haven't noticed so I had
to explain not myself but I had to
explain the Swedish model again and
again and I think precisely for this
reason exactly what Donald Trump talked
about here that everybody did it
everybody except Sweden lockdown
societies entirely and then in that case
first of all why did they do it and it
seemed like Trump didn't have much more
of a suggestion than everybody did it so
we didn't that's actually exactly what
researchers say when they look into this
the moment when Society is locked down
was not related in anyway was impossible
for researchers to find any kind of
correlation with the state of
transmission of the virus geographical
location number or a capacity of the
Health Care system and things like that
the one thing it correlated with was
what did the Neighbors do what did
countries close by you did so it seems
like it was a bandwagon effect rather
than looking into the data the research
and doing a cost benefit analysis people
just did it because obviously it is if
you do a Mis if you make a mistake and
the country suffers it's okay if
everybody did the same mistake then you
could say we had no alternative we just
had to lock down for example but if
you're the odd man out and you make a
decision and your people suffer then
everybody will blame you and so
countries just panicked into this kind
of lockdown policy and and swing was the
one place where that didn't happen
it was I mean in a sense that was a huge
risk right that it requires a certain
um I think courage on the part of
Swedish pandemic authorities
I think it did especially because
um you know they would be the ones to
blame if things went wrong and
um
but what they were saying all the time
is that it isn't us who've taken this
risk we're the one place that actually
didn't enter into an unprecedented Panic
position uh of locking down entire
societies economies schools like that
well health authorities had wargamed
pandemics before the World Health
Organization and and others and no one
has suggested that we should lock down
entire societies but then suddenly when
this happened and China started to lock
down and then Italy everybody just got
on board and I think is also so
interesting about this excuse me
Interruption but the thing I think is so
interesting about this is also that like
China had an especially uh just
astonishingly intense lockdown um you
know neighborhood level enforcers going
door to door and you know these
mandatory quarantines that made it so in
many cases you had families trapped in
their Apartments sort of you know
legitimately unable to even in some
cases go outside for a walk depending on
when the virus was surging in different
neighborhoods and regions
um but the thing that's kind of
interesting is like not all lockdowns
are structured the same and like China's
was considered to
um authoritarian and full-throated and I
guess difficult to enforce for that to
be implemented in other countries but
it's odd because Sweden got I think
especially at the beginning of the
pandemic a different treatment as an
outlier even though China too was an
outlier in its Civ like severity
um that's kind of stunning to me that
the onus is on the
um people emphasizing freedom freedom of
movement uh people's ability to continue
to go to the weddings and funerals of
their loved ones it's fascinating to me
that the authoritarianism didn't require
as much justification but the freedom
did
yeah and let me just jump in there
because because you know uh it was the
the justification that was being used to
criticize Sweden so harshly was always
it wasn't that it was the the death rate
was way out of whack with every other
country that was doing lockdowns it was
specifically
well if you compare it only to the
Nordic it's Nordic neighbors if you
compare only to uh Finland and Norway
and Denmark it looks bad at this this
snapshot in time
um you know if you were comparing it to
the United Kingdom or Italy at that time
it's it's not going to look it's not
going to look as as bad
um and so that that implies that there's
other factors at play perhaps than just
whether you're locking down or not but
uh we have a clip of uh Sweden's State
epidemiologist Anders teniel responding
to exactly that point
um uh that was uh put to him by the uh
BBC interviewer on on a very tough and
and good interview uh back in 2020. so
let's roll uh a segment from that
interview and I'd like for you to
respond to it is no the brutal truth
that you have had many more deaths in
Sweden than you would have had if like
your Scandinavian neighbors you had
imposed an early and very strict
lockdown policy I think that's very
difficult to know I mean the death toll
in Sweden is mainly in the long-term
facilities for long-term ill elderly
people and we had very much an
unfortunate spread in those facilities
in a way that some other countries had
that not there are Nordic neighbors and
and why we are displayed in Sweden and
not in our other neighboring countries
that's something we're trying to
investigate now but but with respect Dr
teniel isn't that part of my point that
you probably would not have had that
catastrophic spread of covid-19 through
your care home homes particularly around
Stockholm if you had run a more strict a
less open policy for the general
population yeah I mean these these
people meet a lot of people even if you
have a lockdown so you can't isolate
them so in that way a lockdown would not
have stopped to spread into them and we
can see now when we are starting to look
at these places
we see a decline in the incidence in
those places once we start really
focusing and getting them to focus on
basic hygiene procedures and so on
so taniel defended himself by saying
that it was too early to say whether
lockdown saved lives or just delayed
inevitable deaths how does that look in
retrospect
yeah there are many factors here and let
me just mention one important difference
here between Sweden and other Nordic
countries we got the virus earlier at an
earlier stage partly because Stockholm
kids are home on a winter break in early
February and many go to the Italian and
Austrian Alps to ski exactly at the
moment when the we had the peak of
transmission in in Italy so it was
already within our uh societies
especially in Stockholm and then the
Elderly Care Homes before there was any
discussion anywhere about locking down
societies so this goes to the three we
saw more of a coronavirus surge in
Stockholm than in you know Malmo for
example because of the timing of school
breaks exactly and that's a very
important point you could see that Malmo
and Gothenburg our second and third City
in Sweden had more of the Norwegian and
danish experience because they didn't go
on a winter break down to Italy at that
time because the winter break comes it's
staggered so it comes at different
moments in time and this goes to one
important traditional point from
epidemiology the reason why they rarely
recommend countries to shut down borders
and and traffic and so on is that the
moment you begin to think about doing
things like that it's already too late
because it happens once the virus is
already there and then you only hurt
yourself in other ways hurting access to
everything from health workers medical
supplies and trade and the economy and
so on not to mention the human toe also
I don't know what your family situation
is but my family like my family split
between the United States and the EU and
so to some degree when you begin to
close off borders it puts a lot of
people in very difficult situation
situations where depending on their visa
status and their passport they might not
see their family members or their loved
ones or their partner for many many
months on end which is a huge human toll
that I think frequently are policy
makers there's no way to attach a
monetary value to that but it is a
profound sense of loss this is such an
incredibly important point because
that's exactly the kind of perspective
that would never appear to uh the
technocrats at the decision table sort
of we've got to have to do something
about X but then there are so many
variables that are incredibly important
to human beings that cannot be
Quantified to that extent and that they
cannot have knowledge about not meeting
your loved ones not meeting friends and
family and so on could be almost as
dangerous to health as uh as getting the
virus so and that's a reason why a
policy based on recommendations gives
you that sort of incredibly important
loophole you're able to do things that
are so important to you so when you look
at the the total death toll and the uh
aspects of Health you'll have to look at
other things as well not just kovid but
also mental illness you're gonna have to
look at domestic abuse you have to look
at suicide or ex loss of exercise and
and social adaptation in schools in uh
friendship circles and and so on
yeah that move from recommendations to
mandates and force was definitely one of
the most disturbing aspects of how
things played out here and we had people
writing you know opinion pieces for the
New York Times saying things like
persuasion is overrated like we we can't
afford to do this kind of kind of stuff
anymore but speaking of those those
technocrats you know let's examine
how well they're pretty some of their
predictions about Sweden uh held up and
one kind of the the premier example
really is this Imperial College of
London model which that was the you know
Neil Ferguson's operation that project
this these were the projections that
policy makers around the world were
using to determine what kind of policy
to implement and what they predicted for
Sweden I just pulled uh some of the
numbers from their uh projections uh and
again as always our sources are linked
in the description of the video and at
reason.com but in green here these are
this is their range of predictions if
Sweden's social distance the whole
population
using Amanda using a lockdown strategy
the total desks they project are between
about thirty thousand and forty two
thousand in red this is the unmitigated
strategy this is you know Sweden doesn't
do lockdowns which is the policy they
they pursued they're projecting between
000 and 90 000 deaths in Sweden the
reality here I pulled from the who's
covid-19 dashboard by the way this
projection was for July 1st so deaths by
July 1st 2020
deaths by July 2nd 2020 were 14
633 so
about half of the projection with a
mitigation strategy uh and then you know
the total death rate was you know uh I
think not even thirty thousand at the
end of the day from from covid-19
continuing through like putting uh
Sweden in the context of other countries
this is from your policy paper or a
slide that I pulled you on we see
Sweden's coveted death rate is pretty
much in the middle of the pack when you
take all of Europe and the us into
account with uh
2322 deaths per million
um and then this was a the really
striking one you'll see Sweden at the
very bottom of this chart because
Sweden's excess death rate during the
pandemic was the lowest in Europe
what do we what do we take from this
fact right here
um why why do do we have any theories as
to why Sweden actually had fewer excess
deaths than the rest of the continent
yeah this is a shocker uh that those
numbers and it tells you first of all I
think that don't put too much trust in
models like that because they can't
really make a serious forecast because
it was all based on just two options
um shutting down Societies or just
business as usual and everybody lives
exactly like they did before the
pandemic they didn't have room for
people actually on a voluntary basis
doing things like working from home
trying to avoid public transportation if
they could and and so on so that's
obviously a major factor Behind These
this data and then when it comes to
Total excess deaths over the three
pandemic years compared to the three
previous years the fact that Sweden
actually had the lowest accrued excess
death rate in Europe and less than half
of America's uh that comes as a surprise
to most people and let me just say that
you can adjust those numbers in
different ways according to the years
you compare it to age structure Health
structure in the population According to
some ways of doing this Denmark beats us
the first place but we're
almost the lowest excess death rates
much lower than countries like Finland
for example who seem to be doing better
during the pandemic so it tells you that
it's not necessarily this dramatic
trade-off between Liberty and health
I do think one other thing that we
should throw in there because Zach and I
were doing some research on this in
preparing for this
um but the you know median age given
that we know that covet is especially
um you know higher mortality for the
elderly versus uh the young uh one thing
we are interested in is okay could one
explanation be that you know countries
with higher excess mortality rates just
had really really old populations and
countries that were more successful are
just young healthy spry
um but in reality I mean the median age
uh in a lot of parts of Scandinavia
Sweden included uh and the United States
it's all roughly comparable and so
that's not a variable that is
um significantly different to some
degree you know I think U.S median age
is something like 38 and I believe it's
the same in Sweden maybe like 39 and so
that is uh commonality
um that I think it's important like to
some degree we have sort of controlled
for that variable in uh assessing this
um I do want to ask though so it's
explain more of the political culture
and some of the characteristics of
Sweden that led to
um you know this really really high
success like to some degree I almost
want to try to learn from this voluntary
model uh it does also seem although I
like your analysis which is blame Italy
a little bit uh for the spread of the
coronavirus in Sweden which I'm totally
on board with blaming Italians as much
as possible
there is an interesting thing that you
know we should talk about which is that
the virus came to Stockholm very very
early on and so tell me about that
experience where coronavirus was
coursing through Sweden but to some
degree maybe that led to Greater herd
immunity earlier on before the vaccine
was developed could you explain that to
us yeah that's right we got it early
February and at full disclosure I was on
a flight from Austria that week as well
a family vacation and I got a call from
a doctor at One hospital who asked me so
were you on that plane on this C in this
seat uh yes I was okay in that case
you'd better check your health because
you I apparently sat next to someone who
had the um the virus so it appeared I
didn't get it at that moment in time but
many people did that early on and I
think it had two effects yes probably
probably as more people were affected at
an early age and at an early stage and
obviously that can help later on to
create some sense of some sort of
immunity against it but also that that
it seemed like it was already too late
to do anything about it the virus was
already here whereas some other
countries like Norway and Denmark
thought that okay it might be heading
our way let's just shut everything down
for a month or or so and that's why it
seemed like Sweden was doing so much
worse
early on uh than than others
and then there are other aspects of
Swedish political culture if you want me
to go into that but well yeah I think we
do want to go into that um and I've got
a good there there was another clip of
uh Anders 10 yelled I think uh will
Broach that topic because Liz and I were
watching this and it just struck us sort
of he's talking about herd immunity
which we just discussed a little bit and
his tone in discussing Sweden's policy
approach his humility was kind of
interesting and uh a contrast to what we
often experience here so let's run that
uh other tenure clip atom
can you regard a situation in which your
country has getting on for 30 000
infections of covid-19 in the population
has a death toll which is significantly
higher than your neighbors standing at
around three and a half thousand can you
regard that as success or do you have to
acknowledge that in some ways your
strategy failed yeah no ma'am that's
true when it comes to the death toll
this didn't work out the way we hoped it
on the other end I mean the connection
between our basic strategy and slowing
down the spread if that's really in the
long run will affect the total death
toll in a society or not that is not
clear yet I mean we know that our
neighboring countries by now have around
one percent of the population
who had some kind of immunity has had
disease we have at least 10 maybe 20
times higher level of immunity in the
population you're inviting me there to
consider the long-term significance of
this notion this concept of herd
immunity now your own government says
that the strategy that you implemented
the more moderate the the the the less
strict uh emergency response to covid-19
was not about establishing herd immunity
but you seem to be suggesting that
actually it is about getting to that
point where so many people in the
general population have had covid-19 and
therefore we can assume have some
resistance to getting it again that you
have this concept of herd immunity in
your population if was that the working
strategy or not no it was not I'm just
pointing out one way that shows that you
cannot make this kind of easy
comparisons at this stage because the
epidemic has hit different countries in
many different ways
so this strikes me as pretty humble
pretty measured and
um like he's actually being honest with
people and allowing them to assess uh
what they think of this strategy on
their own given the data as well as
being pretty clear about the time frames
that we're measuring this is a stark
contrast to what we've seen from Anthony
fauci in the United States explain these
deeper differences in political culture
and how this leads to trust or distrust
in institutions
we this is very interesting because I
think that here Sweden is the outlier
and it's partly a result of uh the kind
of division of uh powers that exist in
government uh and in government in
Sweden so a person like Tang now and the
public health authority in Sweden is not
as politicized as they are in other
places it's not like the President
appoints his sort of top health expert
and then he's supposed to sort of be
almost a politician having an agenda and
defending it whatever happens to to data
and whatever happens to the world uh
those Health authorities other
government agencies in Sweden are
supposed for hundreds of years to be
fairly independent now that's not always
a good thing but it might be in certain
instances because it often means that
they don't have to play politics so the
boss of a an agency is appointed by the
government but on a longer mandate is
not replaced when there's a new
government in town a new
prime minister which means that they're
supposed to be less about a political
agenda more about following the law and
following the data wherever it goes and
that this means that technol doesn't
have to defend any particular ideology
or a political program or anything like
that he tells you what he thinks the
reading of the science is and then the
government is of course free to follow
that advice or reject it but by
tradition they usually come pretty close
and I my suspicion is that one reason is
that if everything fails they can blame
technal for it whereas that would be
much more difficult in a system where
they directly they're they're part of of
the government but is there a mechanism
by which you can remove these Public
Health authorities like how does that
work if say tegnell had performed
terribly
um does being so insulated from
political pressures have a negative
unintended consequence or intended
consequence of making it hard for the
citizenry to fire them yeah no he can be
fired if the government thinks that they
are really doing a lousy job uh they can
throw them out but that's the one thing
they can do they cannot intervene and
sort of tell them constantly what to do
what to say here and there they can just
say we don't have trust in you anymore
so off you go and that rarely happens
then you really have to misbehave in
dramatic ways
um so this has given traditionally then
a government agencies some
independencies to stand free from the
political agenda and that's not always a
good thing because you know many
government agencies are filled with
people who are just obsessed with one
problem and never thinks about cost
benefits and unintended consequences but
um partly out of historical coincidence
uh that wasn't the case this time around
and I think once in a while it's
important when politicians panic because
we could see this that the Norwegian and
danish Health authorities they were
closer to the Swedish agenda the Swedish
model than their politicians were but
since they don't have that division of
powers Danish Norwegian politicians had
to be seen to be doing something
drastically so they shut down borders
and shut down schools even though the
health experts but said this will just
hurt us in in other ways and it won't
help us against the virus this is a
German
oh go ahead Zach well I was just gonna
say you know in that that answer also
that you can kind of see why
other public health officials are not as
forthcoming about admitting mistakes
because in the in that answer he says
yes we did some things wrong and we
wouldn't we don't want to see the death
toll as high as it is and then the way
that that was twisted and reported
around the world was to say teniel
admits that Sweden's anti-lockdown
strategy didn't work and anyone who
watches that Clip In that clip that we
just played in its full context can see
that's not what he's saying he's saying
that unfortunately the virus we were not
aggressive enough in protecting these
Care Centers uh that was a big mistake
and and we're going to go into some of
the the errors in a second here but
could you just comment on the way that
um kind of that
exchange was used against Sweden in the
big picture
yes this was nuts and I was actually
very surprised when I talked to American
and European friends who said that oh
you've apparently uh abandoned your
strategy and uh apologized for it what
how and it turned out that many uh
journalists had been using Clips like
that by technol and others the Prime
Minister even the Swedish King when they
said that yes obviously the high death
toll is a failure that was a problem and
but then moving on to say that uh we
still think it's the best strategy we
think of the long run this will turn out
to be a better way of doing things and
children won't be suffering learning
losses and things like that and yet it
was reported in you know the Washington
Post and the Telegraph and so on that
sort of Tang now
abandons the covid strategy regrets not
imposing lockdowns and and tignanel
obviously rejected all those
interpretations so that tells you how we
became just a uh a symbol of something
that the rest of the world didn't like
and they they wanted to see it fail this
is almost like a lesson in how the four
foreign media works right like the
foreign media's heads just exploded when
faced with a public official who was
actually indicating some amount of
humility and really that should be kind
of a routine thing where you know that's
very easy to incorporate into our
existing hypotheses about how the world
works but instead it was just like you
know completely impossible to comprehend
for them which is kind of a sad
commentary on like the sorry State of
Affairs uh in the United States at least
yeah and that tells you that technol
isn't a politician because a politician
knows that if he ever uses the word
mistake that will be the one thing that
they will talk about but he is more
humble scholar and he's says it like it
is and I think that's I mean that's
often problematic for him but I think
that's an incredibly important when we
evaluate the different models we have to
be it's okay to make mistakes we all
make mistakes it's always a journey of
Discovery and of learning and the tragic
thing is that so many Health agencies
and specifically politicians and
governments they don't want to revisit
what happened because they don't want to
admit any kind of mistakes and in that
case we're not learning anything until
the next time
yeah and that you know the excerpt
we read from the the Sweden's internal
coveted commission at the beginning made
it very clear that they do not think
that the lockdowns or the the
anti-lockdown strategy was a mistake
they do have they do analyze some of the
errors and I want to go through a couple
of those major errors
um that that they pinpoint and ask you
if you agree or disagree one is that um
they say there should have been more
active reception Arrangements put in
place for people returning from winter
break so this goes back to the Italy
problem people vacationing in Italy
they're saying when they should have
when they came back to Stockholm or
wherever and develop symptoms there
should have been a more uh obvious path
for them to get tested and you know
isolate and not spread the virus down
because it would have been a good thing
for the spread to have been a little bit
slower at the beginning as we try to as
a they try to cope with these senior
living facilities the other note here is
that uh you know they say they reiterate
here that other countries unlike Sweden
introduced various types of lockdown and
that they believe the right balance was
struck in keeping preschools and
compulsory schools open switching to
distance learning at colleges
um however we believe that in the middle
of March 2020 there should have been
temporary closures of a number of indoor
settings where people gather or come
into close contacts at the shopping
centers restaurants cultural and sports
events hairdressing salons swimming
pools and the like so reading that it it
does sound to me that this commission
and I don't know exactly who is behind
it but that they do think there should
have been some sort of temporary
what we here in the U.S call lockdowns
and you know my my concern reading that
is you know what is temporary we we saw
what temporary lockdowns were like here
but you know what is your reaction to
um kind of their recommendations as to
what could have been done better
yeah I think that's obviously some
things could have been done better and
the one thing that didn't work out was
having testing in place at an early
stage and and uh you know I mentioned
that I was on a flight and I got this
call that perhaps I should uh try to
stay at home if I could uh because I
might be infected I wasn't offered a
test at that time because they hadn't
scaled that up up and uh I mean many
countries suffered from the same problem
and but obviously that would have helped
to get an indication on whether I should
really
isolate myself and protect my loved ones
from from myself for example
however I don't agree with and I think
there are other things like that I think
that
Elderly Care Homes could have been
protected better from an early stage but
I don't agree with this assessment that
we should have shut down all these uh
these places
um the corona commission is an
independent commission made up of
different experts in different fields
and they think that they can calibrate
and find the exact right way of of
lockdown and making it very temporary at
that moment I should say that there were
restrictions in place Gatherings or
public events were limited to 50
participants in March for example
um public ones only right like people
were still able to host private events
so people were still able to get married
and have religious Services have
funerals the types of private Gatherings
were okay
workplaces shopping centers that was not
included so there were some things like
that when you went to a bar you had to
get a table
um
offerings that you couldn't stand in the
bar and talk and sort of create this
kind of crowd
um
effect so there were some things like
that in place I think it is very easy
for experts afterwards to look at the
exact state of the transmission and how
everything turned out and say right for
this these few weeks alone it would have
made sense to shut this particular thing
down
but that doesn't tell you anything of
how such an attempt would have worked
out at that stage where they would have
it in the right places at the right time
and whether you would open it up at the
right moment which most places countries
didn't do
that's a really good point
um and the with the I was just gonna uh
Linger on the the Elder Care Homes uh
issue because that that seems to be what
everyone agrees on is that you know this
happened in New York City uh that uh you
know this just swept through nursing
homes and that was in part because of a
deliberate policy by the governor of
that state to send infected seniors into
nursing home facilities
um in Sweden I was looking to this issue
just a little bit and this issue of
Science magazine entitled Sweden's
gamble alleges that the hospitals in
Sweden didn't become as overwhelmed as
those in Northern Italy or New York City
but that was in part because many
severely ill patients weren't
hospitalized
um a directive to Stockholm area
hospitals stated patients older than 80
with a BMI above 40 shouldn't be
admitted to intensive care because they
were less likely to recover and that
most nursing homes were not equipped to
administer oxygen so many residents
instead received morphine to alleviate
their suffering so that kind of
complicates the conversation we were
having earlier about Sweden's Health
Care System it almost seems like they
were taking a very
heavy-handed triage approach do you know
much about what happened in the hospital
system or having a you know context that
you can add to that
well you know it's not that that's
difficult to say that there's one
directive that told everybody how to do
since the system is more decentralized
and there were various different uh
ways of doing things in in different
places but yes obviously and I've talked
to doctors about this obviously in many
cases when people were very old uh
having very severe pre-existing
conditions uh they didn't administer
intensive care and uh ventilators and
things like that not for lack of
ventilators because again we had an
excess capacity of even at the peak of
some 20 percent but because it's a very
difficult and painful intervention and
if you think that this won't help at all
then doctors they don't perform those
things and I don't reject the idea that
mistakes were being made that I I don't
have knowledge about that but it's not
that easy to just say that they sort of
have had this brutal triage instead one
mistake that have been done and this
will hopefully change in the future is
that we have a very bizarre form of um
local Regional division of powers which
means that the nursing homes and the
Elderly Care Homes even for uh the olden
and the sick
they're administered by controlled by
cities whereas all the health care and
the hospitals is based in the regions
and this means that we've even had some
bizarre rules saying that nursing homes
are not allowed to hire a medical doctor
because that is what regions do so we
had those silly almost tough Wars
between them and obviously that hurt a
lot of people in in elderly care but
again look at the whole picture of total
excess deaths over all those three years
if Sweden willingly sacrificed human
life as if they were old and had a high
BMI that would show in the statistics
and we wouldn't have the lowest excess
death rates of All European countries in
a sense it seems like the approach that
was being
um
used is not like a ariaster horror movie
mid-summer throwing the old people off
of a cliff type approach uh though that
is very Scandinavian I hear but rather a
palliative care type approach where I
mean fundamentally we're talking about
people over the age of was it 80 I mean
that's very very old who are obese uh
and I think to some degree
um this is something that uh I I don't
think would play very well in the United
States but a palliative care approach
does I think make some amount of sense
and I'm curious uh you know at some
point we should go into that and examine
that more deeply
yeah and as I mentioned at the top of
the show our reason for continuing to
Stage these conversations about covet
policy even as the most harsh measures
are in the rear view mirror is just to
better understand what actually unfolded
and what the real lessons of the
pandemic are
because I don't feel like those lessons
are being absorbed by many of the policy
makers in this country or the
influential media figures who write and
talk about covid I haven't heard any
acknowledgment from the people who
implemented them that lockdowns were a
mistake that school closures were a
mistake much less any apologies I I
don't hear that that Anders taniel
approach to things so I don't think it
makes sense for any of us to drop it
until it becomes crystal clear that
we're not doing this again and Johann am
I off base here do you think the proper
lessons are actually being drawn from
Sweden's example like what if you had to
boil it down what are the lessons that
should be learned
yeah no you are right uh the proper
lessons are not being learned partly
because few people and especially
politicians and authorities they don't
want to revisit the pandemic because
they did things out of panic quite often
and they want the perception to remain
that we didn't have an alternative of
course we made mistakes but we didn't
have an alternative and Sweden is the
counter argument that they don't like
because there was an alternative and
it's so shocking to me to see the
interest in Sweden during the pandemic
we've never had so much International
reporting about Sweden as we did of the
first year of the pandemic and then
silently that was all quiet and
journalists stopped calling they said
that we were a disaster a pariah the
world's cautionary Tale But afterwards
when we have the results why don't they
revisit and follow up and look at the
data that's what we need to do because
again we we make mistakes we're no more
than humans but we have to learn from
those mistakes and make sure that this
is a learning process and what other
what should we learn from the Swedish
experience I think it is that don't
panic don't do just anything against any
kind of problem whatever it is uh even
if it seems like the worst problem there
don't accept any kind of legislation and
control and and measures because there
are always cost benefits there are
always unintended consequences and we
have to take that into consideration as
well
so Americans uh almost have this weird
fixation on Scandinavia you know I I
mean in on this topic we want to use
Sweden as the scapegoat uh but then in a
bunch of other political contexts in the
United States we despite not knowing
very much and being pretty naive about
Sweden who seem to want to emulate it
um I think that the most interesting
example of this Switching gears a little
bit is Bernie Sanders
um so Bernie Sanders will so frequently
call himself a Democratic Socialist and
tout socialism as the model he doesn't
mean Venezuela style socialism he
doesn't mean Cuban style socialism he
means Swedish socialism uh this is
something you have commented on
extensively Johan what are the myths
that Americans my age believe about the
Swedish system is it actually socialist
it's so interesting that the Socialists
keep coming back to Sweden and I think
that's because all their favorite
countries constantly fail every Cuba and
Venezuela end up with bread lines and uh
Millions trying to escape from that that
horror show but they always have Sweden
it seems so friendly and successful and
and yet socialist well the problem of
course is that we have been socialists
in Sweden and we have been successful
but never at the same time that's what
Sanders and the others fail to realize
we had that period in the 1970s and
1980s when Sweden was doubling the size
of public consumption raising taxes
regulating everything and price controls
and what have you and this is the moment
when Bernie Sanders and all those who
are sort of
stuck in the 1970s this is what they
still remember look at Sweden they are
socialists but they're also one of the
richest countries on the planet it seems
to be working in Sweden the problem of
course is that it's like that old joke
how do you end up with a small fortune
well you start with a large fortune and
then you waste most of it and that's
what Sweden did in the 70s and 80s we
were one of the richest countries on the
planet before this experiment and that
was based on a 100 year period of
limited government free markets free
trade as late as 1960 we had lower taxes
than the United States and most European
countries this brought us all the wealth
and all those successful International
companies the Ikeas and stuff that
brought us so much wealth that politics
thought that they could redistribute
everything
and begin to just check up spending and
taxes well they couldn't because the 70s
and 80s that's the one period in modern
Swedish economic history when we lagged
behind other countries this is the
moment when we didn't create a single
net job in the private sector and when
entrepreneurs and businesses left Sweden
Ikea left Sweden tetrapak left Sweden
most successful entrepreneurs left
because it was impossible to do business
in Sweden and this all ended in a
terrible financial crash in the early
1990s so that was a brief period of time
and it's one that we don't want to go
back to since we not even Swedish
socialists even they say that okay we
went too far and the Social Democratic
finance minister at the time said it was
actually absurd and perverse in many
ways what we were trying to do and since
then Sweden has again become successful
but that's based on a new period of
liberalization and of economic reform so
today if Bernie Sanders want to imitate
Sweden he would have to reform Social
Security partially privatize it he would
have to open up and privatize some much
of a product markets deregulate abolish
occupational licensing reduce many taxes
reduce corporate taxes from the U.S
level the bullish property taxes and
inheritance taxes and stuff like that
implementing National School voucher
systems so private schools get the same
funding as as public ones so Sweden
today is not what he remembers from the
1970s it's it's a much better and and
Freer place than it was back then in a
lot of ways this almost feels a little
bit like a Libertarian Paradise not on
every level but I certainly look at you
know obviously Sweden has some areas
that absolutely uh fly in the face of
that like I know homeschooling is banned
in Sweden uh which is very sad but
school choice is massive in Sweden and
then when you look at yes there's a
whole bunch of public sector jobs a
whole bunch of government jobs programs
but one thing that's actually really
interesting that I know you've commented
on a fair bit is the fact that union
relationship relations in Sweden are a
lot less fraught than in the United
States so in the United States you so
frequently see
um you know teachers unions and cop
unions essentially allowing some of the
worst lowest performing employees to to
fester in these roles to never be fired
to have Perpetual constant Eternal job
security completely shielded from the
consequences of their laziness or their
bad actions you see a ton of political
power exercised by unions in the United
States is this different in Sweden it
seems like it's a little bit less toxic
you know relations in workplaces aren't
as confrontational in Sweden uh as it is
in in most other places and uh I would
say the trade unions are more respected
in Sweden broadly than in other places
but as one there was this great
conversation between two trade unionists
an American and a Swede when the
Americans said oh we would love to have
the kind of respect and attention and
power as you do in Sweden and the
Swedish Trade union has said in that
case you have to deserve it and and
that's one major difference this shocks
Americans the Swedish trade unions one
of their most important goals is to make
sure that wage increases aren't too high
aren't true that they don't get too high
wages because that will make their
businesses less competitive so the sort
of the the Trade union Federation is
traveling around the country and trying
to sort of get the local trade unions to
relax don't try to get everything at
once because we're a small open economy
we have to stay competitive and make
sure that wages don't increase faster
than productivity
um and that's obviously not the same
trade unions as you've seen in other
places some explain this with the fact
that we have much higher Trade union
membership rates in Sweden than in other
places 70 80 percent even in in White
Collar professions and as some
economists like Monica Olson has pointed
out if your trade unions are represent
such a large part of the population then
you can't just
get everything on everybody else's
expense in that case you have to think
about the competitiveness of of the
whole economy you're also a consumer so
it doesn't make sense to uh Lobby for
tariffs for example so many things are
different in Sweden than than in the US
I think it's worth uh playing a bit of
Bernie Sanders rhetoric just to really
dig into a couple of the specific claims
that he makes when he you know touts the
Swedish DSA model let's roll that clip
and I I'm curious to hear you react to
some of the specifics that he does for
someone who calls himself a socialist to
be elected president United States well
so long as we know what democratic
socialism is and if we know that in
countries in Scandinavia like Denmark
Norway Sweden they are very Democratic
countries obviously the voted turnout is
a lot higher than it is in the United
States in those countries Healthcare is
a right of all people in those countries
college education graduate school is
free in those countries retirement
benefits Child Care are stronger than in
the United States of America and in
those countries by and launch government
works for ordinary people in the middle
class rather than as is the case right
now in our country uh for the
billionaires I can hear the Republican
attack ad right now he wants America to
look more like Scandinavia that's right
that's right
so uh and by the way that was from ABC
this week uh when Bert in 2015 when
Bernie was running for president and
some of the things he mentioned there
turn uh turnout a more generous social
safety net free college more General
equality you know you mentioned some of
the University Market yes yes so
um
is that something that is you know
crucial to Sweden's uh society and kind
of cultural success
you know this is why Sweden is not a
Libertarian Paradise we might have free
markets but we do have a very generous
welfare state and uh it's true that many
of these things are are handed out by by
the government not always it's funded by
the government at least often there are
private providers but the thing is we
pay for these things ourselves that's an
incredibly important point to to make
because you know there's this pipe dream
of Bernie Sanders and others that this
will somehow be paid for by the rich but
Sweden learned in the 1970s that you if
if you have you
you can pick one a big generous will
first date or you can make the rich pay
for it all you can't have both if you
have a universal generous welfare state
uh in if and make the rich pay for it
all they will stop being rich they will
move they will stop starting those
businesses and the IPS of the future
will move again instead you have to get
most of the taxes from low and middle
income High hold households that's the
Dirty Little Secret of the Swedish
welfare state that the the Socialists
loves the poor taxpayers because they
are reliable loyal taxpayers they don't
Dodge they don't move to Monaco they
don't have tax attorneys so we have the
bulk of our government revenue coming
from
um Regional local income taxes which are
flat income taxes not Progressive and
even the sort of the the national uh
level kicks in uh
among fairly fairly unfairly low incomes
also things like a value-addy tax at 25
percent in General on most Goods which
is obviously regressive the poor pay as
much as the rich when they buy food and
in in taxes and this means that when the
oecd club of mostly rich countries look
at different tax systems around the
world they say that the Swedish system
is one of the least progressive tax
systems of all much less Progressive
than the United States because America's
welfare states is so small so you can
rely more on the rich whereas here we
all have to to pay for it so the Swedish
welfare state mostly just redistributes
over an individual's life cycle we get
lots of stuff when we're young and in
preschool and school and then we work
hard and pay for it all and then we get
much of it back in healthcare and and
retirement benefits which mostly means
that yes we get lots of stuff but we pay
for it all and it means that nothing
much is different from paying it
straight out of pocket than the fact
that we only get it back when and if the
government decides that this is a
valuable thing this is how you should
spend your money do you think that
Norway will at any point adopt the
Swedish model because I know Norway does
it a little bit differently but they've
experienced huge issues with capital
flight in recent years it's a little bit
of a stereotype at this point having
multi-millionaires and billionaires
fleeing Scandinavia to go to like
Switzerland uh for tax avoidance reasons
will will Norway emulate Sweden because
the Swedish system is more successful
well that's a a we as swedes would love
to see that happening sorry that's the
the cat she always you know cats are
nature's Arch individualists says Albert
J knock put it so if there's a recent
discussion she wants to be a part of it
um so so at sweets we would love to see
our Scandinavians neighbors realize that
we did it in the best way or this time
actually the Danes are according to
economic freedom of the world more free
market than than the sweets the
Norwegians aren't and you know they have
oil
and that makes all the difference
because they get so much government
revenue from oil so if your policy is to
strike oil then a a more generous
welfare state with less free markets
might be sustainable for for a longer
period of time
how does the welfare the large welfare
state affect sort of this social issues
because that that's often where we see
things get there's often a a correlation
there where when the welfare state
becomes more generous people for
instance want less immigration because
they see Outsiders as coming in and
taking their benefits away how is that
how have issues like that played out in
Sweden
yes this is I think my main fear when it
comes to this generous welfare state
it's not really what it costs but what
it buys and the kind of attitudes that
change with it in in several ways you
know we have a traditional work ethic in
in Sweden and a tradition of trying to
be honest in relationships with
government agencies and so on which goes
hundreds of years back in time a long
time before we had a welfare state a
long time before we were Rich even which
I think in this goes too far uh to
discuss here but I think it goes back to
the fact that Sweden was never a feudal
society was more self-owning um property
owning small farmers instead and that
affects attitudes well once you but so
cultures come from a certain place and
when you remove those incentives and
change the system it might erode some of
these attitudes and we've seen some
worrying things about like that in in
polling how swedes are suddenly think
it's it's okay to lie and and and cheat
to get government benefits something
that my grandparents generation think
would be would be absolutely horrible
um we do see some changes in in the work
ethic in in certain uh areas of society
and we definitely see a rise of
nationalist sentiments you know we yes
we want a generous welfare state but we
don't want to share it with uh Somalians
and with the
um Afghan Afghanistan's nice and uh
we've seen the rise of a 20 far-right
party in Sweden which has quite a sway
over our policy right now in Sweden so
things change once you begin to play
around with these social attitudes well
this is a thing that I think about so
much uh and this is the flip side of it
that I think many uh self-described
Democratic socialists in the United
States won't recognize but I mean Sweden
has much lower poverty than the United
States does and frankly uh less liberal
less welcoming policy toward immigrants
and even of its Nordic neighbors Sweden
is Far and Away in my understanding the
most welcoming to immigrants uh and even
even at that
um it's really it doesn't have nearly
the same levels of immigration that the
United States does I mean I think
there's something like what I mean
single digits in most Nordic countries
are actually foreign born and then I
look around my home New York City and
we're about 40 foreign born this is just
your society and your welfare state will
be structured so differently based off
of how
um relaxed you are how welcoming you are
toward immigrants and I think this is
something that so much of the
progressive left in the U.S feels to
reconcile uh the fact that like if you
actually want the Nordic system to be
emulated do you want that part of it to
be emulated too because that
fundamentally has to be dealt with a
little bit more uh do you have any
reactions to that in terms of that
trade-off between welfare states and
immigration do you think Sweden should
be approaching that differently
you know this is so interesting people
can be absolutely devoted to the ideals
of equality and we should almost all of
us have exactly the same kind of income
level and lifestyle and then the moment
you mention Nigeria or you mention uh
Iraq then suddenly they say obviously
not on that level it should be sort of
just us here we should have perfect
equality and that tells you something
about how little Universal they are in
their their frame of of reference and of
mind and how really discriminatory some
of these policies uh are and
interestingly I think this is one area
where Bernie Sanders has talked about
how ideals about open borders and free
migrations and that's dangerous to
socialism that's more like a Koch
brothers idea because it would be
impossible in the long run to welcome
everybody and um if if we also want this
kind of generous welfare state and this
is the Paradox this is what we're seeing
right now with the reaction in not just
Nordic countries but all over Europe I
think to migration
the government doesn't say in swedes
nowadays don't tell people ask people so
what kind of life would you prefer
what kind of set of Institutions and
benefits would you uh prefer they say
you want the best you want access to
government-funded preschool and and
school and Healthcare you want all this
stuff so because we can't accept
anything less for you and oh that's so
expensive so we can't accept you
so you're gonna have to stay in a place
in often ruthless despotic dictatorships
with no chance of improving the lives of
yours and and your loved ones and this
to me is one of the uh most Stark uh
illustrations of the hypocrisy of uh the
the Socialist ideals of perfect equality
within those walls and you don't let
anybody in
yeah it's really frankly quite tragic
um Johan Norberg thank you so much for
talking to us I hear you have a new book
out the capitalist Manifesto and where
can people find that book where can
people find you if they want to keep
following your work
well they can I think the best way is
just to Google Johan Norberg and you can
add something like the Cajun Institute
and then you'll find uh most of my stuff
and the um and the book as well
um but I'm everywhere on social media if
you just look for Joe and Norberg
wonderful thank you so much for talking
to reason this was truly enlightening
and I apologize to our viewers but Zach
and I will continue to be chronicling
some of the abject policy failures of
the covid era uh for a while longer
because it's important to learn from
these mistakes thank you so much